dinosaurs from outer space a future
Trilogy without the legacy cast a
never-ending series that keeps getting
worse with every season let's face it
there are a myriad of ways that Jurassic
Park franchise might take a turn for the
worst life uh
finds a way it was no easy feat for the
first Jurassic world film to be released
ideas for a fourth installment have been
bouncing around since the release of
Jurassic Park 3 in 2001 with Spielberg's
and an entertainment commissioning
screenwriters on multiple occasions
throughout the 2000s however no story
ideas ever got off the ground until 2012
when Rick Jaffa and Amanda Silva were
hired to pen the screenplay utilizing
some of Spielberg's ideas Colin travaro
was hired to direct in 2013 rewriting
Jaffer and Silva's drafts with longtime
collaborator Derek Connolly part of
their contribution to the script
involved cutting out previous cast
members from the franchise such as Laura
Dunn and Richard Attenborough travaro
told IGN I respect those actors too much
to shoehorn them into this story for my
own sentimental reasons their instincts
paid off as critics praise the film was
one of 2015's best summer Blockbusters
it goes to show that audiences
appreciated trevaro's determination to
do right by Jurassic Park Fanatics
though it poses a big dilemma for any
future continuation for the franchise it
would need the perfect combination of
the right Story the right director the
perfect stars and a healthy amount of
fan service who knows how long that
could take for all of those conditions
to be met again it's also fair to wonder
if producers will continue to respect
ravaro's desire to maintain the
Integrity of the franchise we all know
how Hollywood can be they very well
might brush him aside and assign someone
else to helm the next installment a hack
who's more interested in swiftly
knocking out a subpass screenplay for
some cash and clout rather than giving
the Jurassic Park Cannon the respect it
deserves hate this hacker crap don't get
us wrong we know that critics and fans
alike seem to agree that travaro's
trilogy as a whole is good but not great
in the end nothing compares to the
original Jurassic Park how'd you do this
the lost world was pretty forgettable
Jurassic Park 3 was better but also very
meh despite some Neil's return to the
spotlight Jurassic world appease critics
and the rest of us all the same but
leaned into some pretty silly ideas that
linger throughout the new Trilogy mainly
Owen Grady's ability to train and
befriend one of the most deadly and
intelligent predators to ever exist on
Planet Earth Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom had the usual Thrills but was a
narrative nightmare Jurassic world
Dominion killed at the box office but
was torn to shreds by critics however
despite its shortcomings it's pretty
much a unanimous opinion that the
highlight of dominion is the inclusion
of the original cast Dr Grant
here I'm uh I'm owing Grady big fan I
read your book
well book on tape that way your parents
says that well enough into the narrative
to not be cringy and they add a
Nostalgia factor that was sorely missing
from the first two installments of the
trilogy nonetheless so they were warmly
welcomed back into the franchise it
sounds like the minion will be their
Collective swan song let's finish this
yeah
speaking with stuff about his decision
to return and to sorts in the future of
Jurassic Park in general Neil said this
may be the end of the franchise I'm not
sure but it'll certainly be the last for
us when you consider how much stronger
the trilogy is as a whole because of the
original Trio's inclusion it's easy to
worry about our future Jurassic Park
movies would fare without relying on the
legacy cast to tie the overarching plot
together in the end keep in mind that
Jeff Goldblum has implied in interviews
that there could be more dinosaurs in
the future but it goes without saying
that his appearance alone in a future
installment wouldn't carry the same
weight as the entire Trio if you don't
agree sit down and watch the lost world
again and get back to us
[Music]
Tony is the original cast throwing in
the towel but so are some of the new
Mainstays of the franchise according to
Chris Pratt's his time as a velociraptor
training alpha male Owen Grady is up
back up he told total film it's the
perfect bookends to this franchise as
long as there's an opportunity for a
brand to exist there are probably going
to be things but as far as my
involvement to me it feels like a great
organic ending this is definitely
Ryerson being that the character of Owen
Grady is more or less the centerpiece of
travaro's Trilogy alongside Bryce Dallas
Howard's Claire Deering of course and
according to Howard she's done too she
told total film I don't know what's
possible from here but since the end of
the road for my character and for so
many of these characters in terms of it
being the completion of our arcs which
is exciting and emotional and powerful
and eventful these are by no means empty
words from either of the co-stars as
they're both bugged up with future
creative prospects in 2023 Pratt debuted
the voice of one of the most iconic
video game characters of all time Mario
in illuminations a Super Mario Brothers
movie judging by its box office success
it will be the beginning of a long
future for Nintendo's most popular
franchise
you know
Mario besides that he's also expected to
fill the role of the lasagna loving
Garfield in an upcoming animated film
set to be released in 2024. who knows
that might also take a step towards
franchise territory if it ends up being
better than previous attempts meanwhile
Howard has been moving towards directing
over the past few years with her feature
directorial debut being the 2019
documentary dads since then she's
directed episodes for the Mandalorian
and the Book of Boba Fett and is set to
helm a remake of Flight of the Navigator
while it's silly to say that big name
actors like Pratt and Howard are capable
of multitasking it really does sound
like they're done with dinosaurs that
being said imagining a future Jurassic
Park franchise without both the original
cast and the two main stars of the
latest Trilogy is difficult to say the
least
many of the issues people had with the
Jurassic world Trilogy were in regard to
how close they have followed the stories
and events of the first Trilogy Of
course some of that is inherent to the
plus which follows the employees and
scientists who work for a
dinosaur-themed amusement park that
becomes a site of a disaster you have to
admit that though it's repetitive it
isn't unbelievable considering how
plausible it is for Rich investors to
make the same mistake twice and risk
thousands of lives for no reason other
than lighting their pockets nonetheless
producers will have to explore other
plot Avenues if they want to fill up
movie theaters and gross over a billion
dollars again the most logical and
likely next step would be a continuation
of the ongoing plot so far every
installment in the Jurassic Park Cannon
has sprung forth from the events of the
original movie so it would only make
sense for filmmakers to continue on with
this approach while most of the major
character arcs are tied off nicely in
Dominion there's still an entire world
filled with Dinosaurs to contend with
and thus plenty of opportunity to use
minor characters to perpetuate the
franchise Colin travaro spoke with the
rap about how even though he's keen on
passing the directorial duties under
someone else he hopes he'll work with
what he sets up for them he said I think
there's another director out there who's
gonna look at this new world that we've
created and hopefully consider the new
characters that we've built in this
movie specifically the Wonder Wiser's
Kayla watts and Mama do arche's
character Ramsay Cole and teaching luck
men to be a gift I think they're all
amazing and hopefully someone will be
inspired and he or she can take this
into the future besides the characters
travaro mentioned there's also the
possibility of assigning a major role to
Jake Johnson's Lowry one of the main
sources of comic relief in Jurassic
World
[Music]
something for once in your life why do
you have to make it personal he likely
would have had plenty of screen time in
dominion and had not been for the
pandemic in case you don't recall his
character's absence was explained away
very briefly when Franklin explains to
Owen and Claire that Lowry along with
others we met in the first film of the
new Trilogy were hired by the CIA
ultimately the question is are any of
these characters interesting enough to
build an entire new installment around
opinions May differ but it's not out of
line for us to worry about such an
approach ending up flaccid in the end
another possibility is that producers
May scrub the idea for suing a new
installment of the film franchise
altogether given the lackluster box
office performances of numerous big
budget franchises these past few years
it's possible that producers will view
the financial success of the Jurassic
world Trilogy as a happy accident and ER
on the side of caution This Time Around
by letting the dinosaurs run a mark in
an ongoing series instead but they've
already tried this out to some extent
with Jurassic world come Cretaceous
which debuted on Netflix in 2020 Five
Seasons later the Animated Series has
come to an end most of its content
coinciding with the events of the
Jurassic world Trilogy it's very
possible that producers will petition
for a live action series that delves
into the dinosaur-infested world that
the minion left us with if they go this
route the possibilities for new
complications and new characters will be
pretty much endless however we all know
how often TV series sour and crumble if
they overstay their welcome so it's
perfectly sensible to Rory about one of
the most beloved franchises of all time
being stretched and mutated beyond
recognition for the sake of soliciting
new streaming subscribers if the reality
of a Jurassic world TV series comes to
pass we can only hope that producers
take Harvey Dent's philosophy into
consideration and end it all on a high
note you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain and don't forget about the
opposite end of the spectrum where
showrunners pull the plug before it
makes sense to do so that's a whole
different brand of nightmare all
level-headed postulation aside there's
definitely a less optimistic side of us
that worries about the franchise veering
off into outlandish Realms you can't
deny that something Grady being able to
train Velociraptors and lead them on a
hunt in the jungle while riding a
motorcycle is a pretty far leap in terms
of plausibility when compared to the
events of the initial Jurassic Park
Trilogy who's to say that the team
behind whatever comes next won't take
some extreme creative Liberties and push
the story beyond the limits of
reasonable expectations sure this sort
of cash grabbing dive into the Absurd is
more common with horror franchises than
anything else such as Halloween
Hellraiser Friday the 13th and saw to
name a few but what about the Fast and
Furious franchise there we have an
example of a franchise very much rooted
in reality but eventually we see Dom on
the gang jump cars over nuclear
submarines and fly cars in space and all
other source of shenanigans that almost
render the original film unrecognizable
who's to say that this will never happen
to the Jurassic Park franchise while
Fast and Furious fans Lively seem to be
a okay with leading into increasing
levels of narrative Madness the same
probably can't be said for us dinosaur
diehards even though the science behind
Jurassic Park has always been a little
wonky we still don't have to will
ourselves too hard in order to suspend
our disbelief imagine an endless string
of yearly Jurassic Park installments
that continually subvert our
expectations with plots that involve
all-out war with hyper-intelligent
Raptors from space all the emergence of
a biotech company that's found a way to
cross-breed humans with Dinosaurs for
the purpose of carrying out nefarious
missions around the world laugh or scarf
all you want but that last one was
actually in the works at one point
before Jurassic world came to be there's
concept art and everything it's a crazy
world out there and the Jurassic Park
franchise is anything but safe from
extreme levels of exploitation and
creative tomfoolery let's just hope it
remains sacred if for no other reason
than pure luck or disinterest
please